s'inquiète des pokémon l'année 2000
l'âme et pokémon pocket monsters monstre
de bosch en français monstre tout court
pour certains adultes n'a lutté contre
dorothée à l'époque de dorothée
aujourd'hui on essaie de lutter contre
les pokémon trois ans après leur
apparition au japon
les pokémon ont envahi les écrans de
gameboy des jeunes français ça se vend
20 fois mieux qu'un jeu classique dans
le jeu il s'agit d'élever des pokémon
les collectionner il y en a 150 et
devenir maître pokémon des heures et des
heures pour y arriver
alors parfois il faut poser des limites
alors vous vous rappelez dimanche soir
je les récupère pokémon d'un jeu débine
n'allez pas dire ça à david 14 ans et
quelques arguments que c'est quand même
il faut quand même réfléchir c'est pas
j'attaque jeu bourrine j'attaque
joubouri ya 150 pokémon faut assimiler
les attaques de chacun savoir ce qu'il
faut faire
anticiper sur ce que l'autre va faire
pour trancher la question il a fallu
consulter deux psychiatres pour serge
tisseron les pokémon comporte un
mécanisme d'identification et
d'acceptation ok mon rang d'ougarit va
utiliser son poids le poké manque
éternue tout le temps il va utiliser son
souffle et c'est comme si l'enfant a été
invité un peu à se reconnaître dans une
image de lui ou où il est engagé à
utiliser presque ses faiblesses des
aspects de lui qu'il n'a pas choisie
pour le meilleur pour son confrère
samuel lepastier c'est de la violence
n'est rien d'autre les relations entre
les êtres vivants entre les animaux sont
beaucoup plus différenciée vous livrons
ci simplement à se taper sur la gueule
envoyez un rayon à anesthésier l'autre à
l'hypnotiser et à le détruire
sous une autre forme les pokémon se sont
imposés dans les cours de récré en 2000
aussi dans sa version jeu de cartes à
collectionner et au singe je les connais
tous les 150 sièges
oui
un phénomène de mémoire pour retenir
tous les noms des personnages des
reconnaître on aimerait bien voir ça en
conjugaison en mathématiques
si ce n'était qu'une question de mémoire
dans un collège en normandie il a fallu
interdire les cartes
elle était au coeur d'un trafic entre
lmp placement cher une carte
voilà mais bon personne n'achète dos en
france
ça tourne autour de 80 si on va la
rendre la franchise japonaise n'a cessé
de se développer avec un tournant
particulier en 2016
pokémon go ou la chasse aux petits
monstres sur smartphone cette fois les
adultes s'y sont mis et ont causé un
accident de voiture et intrusion dans
des espaces privés avec un jeu à
l'origine pour enfants